[Música]
y en directo américa edición nocturna
tenemos este espacio con la información
económica por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero jorge hurtado jorge
buenas noches bienvenido el banco
mundial y el fondo monetario
internacional comenzaron su reunión y
reevalúan una economía marcada por la
inflación y la guerra valentina las
primeras impresiones vinieron de parte
del banco mundial que de hecho rebajó
sus perspectivas de crecimiento
económico a nivel global para 2022 en
casi un punto porcentual según
declaraciones de david malpass
presidente del banco mundial la
previsión de crecimiento para este año
pasa del 3 al 3,2 por ciento desde el
4,1 por ciento como consecuencia de la
guerra en ucrania el funcionario agregó
que la mayor caída de las previsiones de
crecimiento del banco era por la
contracción del 4,1 por ciento en la
región de europa y asia central a nivel
global se redujo la perspectiva de
crecimiento para las economías avanzadas
y otras en desarrollo debido a la subida
de los precios de los alimentos y sobre
todo la energía para mañana se espera
que el fondo monetario internacional
también rebaje sus previsiones aunque
pese a la caída generalizada el fm ha
dicho que la mayoría de los países en
territorio positivo bueno pues una
noticia que nos alegre en medio de todo
y es que en este contexto tan complejo
la economía china parece repuntar el
dato fue brindado hoy por las
autoridades chinas y muestran que esa
economía creció un 4,8 por ciento entre
enero y marzo de este año respecto al
mismo período del año pasado china vive
desde marzo varios confinamientos en
ciudades importantes como shanghai o
guandong considerado el centro de
fabricación mundial para los economistas
el crecimiento presentado hoy se basa en
los datos de enero y febrero y no
refleja el impacto real de estos
confinamientos chinas se propuso un
objetivo de crecimiento del 5.5 por
ciento para este año pero ahora hay
cautela porque de las 100 principales
ciudades de china que más aportan a su
producto interno bruto sólo 13 de ellas
se salvan de las restricciones porque el
presidente ruso vladímir putin aseguró
que los mayores perjudicados por las
sanciones contra rusia vienen de
occidente o están en occidente putin
también dijo que su economía marcha muy
bien que de hecho la inflación se está
estabilizando y que la demanda minorista
en el país se normaliza de alguna forma
pero el último dato de la inflación
rusia revela que los precios al
consumidor se dispararon al 17 5% en
términos interanuales en un mes y medio
además la presidenta del banco central
de rusia advirtió a los diputados de la
duma estatal que las reservas del país
están por terminarse y que la crisis
rusa llegará entre el segundo y el
tercer trimestre de 2022 las reacciones
de putin se dan luego de que úrsula von
der leyen presidenta de la comisión
europea afirmara que la quiebra de rusia
es sólo cuestión de tiempo escuchemos
que dijo
podemos decir con confianza que esa
política con respecto a rusia ha
fracasado la estrategia de la guerra
relámpago económica resultó infructuosa
las sanciones consiguieron el objetivo
de sus iniciadores y proximidad y sunny
in its atrás me refiero al aumento de la
inflación el desempleo y el
empeoramiento de la dinámica económica
de eeuu y europa el descenso del nivel
de vida de los europeos y la devaluación
de sus ahorros
en américa latina' varios países
continúan con la inflación al alza
aunque ya surgen algunas propuestas
económicas el presidente guillermo lazo
de ecuador propuso crear una gran zona
de libre comercio en américa
la sucia reunión con el presidente
argentino alberto fernández en buenos
aires para discutir sobre la comunidad
de estados latinoamericanos y caribeños
entre otros temas escuchamos
en el celac en noviembre del año pasado
tuve la oportunidad de plantear al celac
una visión un poco práctica en el
sentido de que si quisiéramos emular a
la unión europea el primer paso que
tenemos que dar es una gran zona de
libre comercio para poder tener una
mayor fuerza y poder negociar con otras
regiones del mundo de una manera más
potente todos unidos en américa latina y
el caribe bueno y finalizamos este
espacio con la cifra al día es 7 por
ciento eso aumentó el precio del gas en
eeuu el gas natural estadounidense
alcanzó un máximo de 13 años superando
brevemente los 8 dólares por primera vez
desde 2008 esto por un aumento de la
demanda a los futuros del primer mes
cerraron con esta alza la última vez que
los precios aumentaron tanto fue agosto
2008 cuando los huracanes amenazaron las
platas forma de gas en el golfo de
mexico porque usted muchas gracias por
esta ampliación económica continúen con
nosotros hacemos una pausa y ya volvemos
aquí en directo américa edición nocturna
[Música]